near members of the Parliament we have
already presented to you the European
Green Deal communication our new growth
strategy and the European Green Deal
investment plan as well as the just
transition mechanism to support
territories most affected by energy
transition the next big step is the
climate law which we will propose a
binding climate neutrality targets for
EU in 2050 we will conduct impact
assessment until summer we had adopted
yesterday our 5g communication and will
soon present a new European Data
strategy and the white paper on
artificial intelligence we need to
protect fundamental rights but want our
industry to work with artificial
intelligence and innovate we will soon
adopt an action plan to deepen the
capital markets Union focusing on
tackling regulatory barriers in existing
legislation and structural barriers and
making sure that SMEs have access to
finance and this would become the part
of our wider SME strategy last but not
least on the rule of law the Commission
will intensify its preventive work for
example with its first rule of law
report which will assess the situation
in all Member States this report will
have a sound methodology and form the
basis for future work on the rule of law
thank you very much